good evening the decision was cast today
to re-brand mccarran international
airport and honor former senator harry
reid
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise feldick i'm kirsten joyce brian
has the night off
the approval will now spark an expansive
and thorough process
christian casarez has been monitoring
this decision joins us now in studio
with more
on why some folks are not thrilled about
this particular change
christian that's right well harry reid
international airport will be the new
identity but before that happens it
needs to be approved
by the faa that change brought many
nevadans to speak out today
about the value of the new identity the
change was spearheaded by commissioner
tick segerblam who
to honor senator harry reid and his
30-year work representing nevada
a huge tribute he says while the former
democrat leader is still alive
the name of of the former senator pat
mccarron was bestowed on the airport
for his work in the 1930s but strong
criticism
over years of racism and xenophobia and
anti-semitism
sparked a change today many nevadans
expressed mixed concerns
over a new airport identity i believe
it's kind of a political move to put
senator reid's name on it
if you're really concerned about senator
mccarron
and some things that he might have done
well okay
then call it the las vegas metropolitan
airport
he isn't a man of many words but of
profound words when meeting him in 2005
he spoke about the growing latino
community in a way i had not heard in
nevada
a name change was proposed in the past
but current lawmakers at the time
rejected the idea
the next step will be a submission to
the faa for
final approval now in terms of
rebranding the commissioner says a
fundraiser will
have to happen to raise about two
million dollars that's the estimated
cost that he says will
not fall on taxpayers christian gossip
is 8 news now